[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new flash
footage let's break it down it looks
like the black racer but what they're
calling it is a time rate there is no
time rate in DC comics this is an
original creation of the show but I
think it's them doing the black flash
without actually doing the black flash
so that at some point in the future they
can do the real black flash from the
comics the episode is titled flashback
which is kind of adorable Barry goes
back in time to try and learn from the
reverse flash the Harrison wells reverse
flash how to get faster he's at the end
of his rope he can't use velocity nine
because it's so dangerous so he's just
exhausting every possible Avenue so this
is a measure of last resort
going back to learn from the man that he
hates so we're gonna see a lot of
familiar things he's basically traveling
back to that Pied Piper episode from
season 1 so we'll see all those events
from a slightly different perspective
you see him fighting with himself so at
some point the Barry of the past is like
what the hell is going on Harrison wells
as we can see totally figures it out
clocks him in the back of the head who
the f are you there is a time right here
time wraiths
only appear when someone messes around
with time-travel who does not understand
it so it sounds like whatever Barry does
to get back to that point he totally
derps and that is what leads to the
creation of this time wraiths so maybe
he changes something that he's not
supposed to change but the Harrison
wells reverse flash was the one who
originally told him the first time he
time traveled that you should not do
that under any circumstance anytime you
try and change the past to avoid some
dangerous event in the future time will
find a way to replace that event with
something that's just as bad if not
worse you can kind of see the overall
message start to emerge especially after
last week's episode you take a shortcut
you pay the price shortcuts are not the
way to go
so Barry trying to take a shortcut in
this episode by going back in time is
going to lead to the consequence of
rates so the other really big thing that
you may have noticed recently is that
even though the flash supergirl
crossover is next Monday the end of this
week's episode of the flash episode 16
did not address that in any way so
apparently the production schedules are
all out of whack so the way they explain
it on the flash is going to be out of
order with Supergirl
whatever but just for fun I'm gonna
explain who the black flashes from the
comics not to be confused with the black
racer or the cosmic entity death there's
a couple different ways that the comics
personify death the black flash is just
specific to people that have the Speed
Force the black racer is the living
embodiment of death amongst the new gods
so he's a much more broader character
the black flash only appears before the
death of a speedster I know it sounds a
little crazy but in the comics recently
Barry became fused with the black racer
not the black flash so he is the new god
of death black flash you could think of
as the god of speedster death yay for
comics being totally confusing so the
black flash is a bit more of a trippy
idea you will not be surprised by this
he was created by Grant Morrison one of
the trickiest weirdest comic book
creators in the world in Mark Millar
they came on to the flash in the late
90s after Mark Waid had left the title
but before Jeff Jones came on so they
had like this really really short run
where they introduced the idea of the
black flash and literally led Wally West
outrun his own death he runs to the end
of time to outrun his own death it is
the weirdest story in the world it
actually starts in flash vol 2 number
138 if you want to read it but that was
meant to be like a really small bookend
run before Geoff Johns came on the title
and completely reinvigorated the wall at
West character and at the end of that
Wally West run he did flash rebirth
brought back Barry Allen and it's one of
the most amazing comic book runs of all
time so no you don't need to read about
the black flash he's a really
interesting idea that Geoff Johns
revisited but if you are a really big
Grant Morrison fan you should totally
check it out I do think it's sometime
the flash TV show will try to do an
actual black racer it's too big of a
concept for them to completely avoid but
because it's really trippy they're gonna
have to find an organic way to do it
without it feeling gimmicky and on top
of that their main villain this season
is wearing a black costume so already it
feels kind of redundant but let me know
in the comments what are you most hype
about for the next week's episode of the
flash seeing Eddie again because Rick
cuz net did come back to guest star I
don't know if they're gonna bring him
back on in a future season it would have
to be earth to Eddie I think he'll
continue to be a guest arm pop
every once in a while at least once a
year just for fun but I can't wait to
see Tom Cavanagh be that angry
reverse-flash character again I mean I
love the Matt ledger you Bart dawn but
some of my favorite season 1 scenes
where when the Harrison wells
eobard thawne character went completely
off the rails so really big heads up I'm
sure you all probably know Batman V
Superman is dropping tonight pretty much
everywhere around the world if it has
not already dropped I'm gonna be seeing
it I'll post my non-spoilery review and
then I'll do an Easter Egg video with
spoilers on Friday so in that spirit
giveaway time congratulations to
flashiness you win a gift card for two
IMAX movie passes be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details I will
keep doing the giveaway through next
week so the next round of the giveaway
will start whenever I post that
non-spoilery Batman V Superman video so
just look out for that tonight while you
guys wait for that video to post tonight
you can click here for my flash episode
from this week and you can click here
for all my Batman V Superman videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
high five I'll see you guys tonight